we talked about weed yeah let's talk
about some weed talked about it by
Hammond if yeah if yeah there was some
weed around here before
and I know you smoked the good stuff
because I've smoked some of your weed
before yeah you got that oil I do I do
and it was almost like being on
something else that isn't weed
if that isn't weed I mean I do think
it's something beside weed oh there's
something else do all the oil is
something else yeah
so you in the movie you talk about how
you think that weed could actually I
mean everything that you're talking
about here from the you know out there
stuff to whatever it is it's sort of
related back to just kind of freeing the
mind your whole thing is think freeing
the mind thinking about thing yeah so
why is it like that I like starting from
there why why is it like this not how
did it get that way
as there's a lot of [ __ ] idiots say
how did it get that way right I was
inducted into a real smart group when I
was very young
and my teacher told me only victims
asked why or how did it get like that
Matt so they're a little that's their
sphere out right that's the reality
remember something else right that's
something because we live in such a
victim culture right everyone is always
well I always talk about the oppression
Olympics here where everyone's trying to
show you how they're the most depressed
and the system's most rig begins to them
but what you're saying is don't it's not
about why it is but now it's about just
it is it is it is so now use it right
like that's the next step as you're
saying it's his fault I can't change it
Wow [ __ ] my pants
no that's big baby [ __ ] there isn't
grandmother [ __ ] that's big one baby
[ __ ] and women change their pants
forever but I mean come on stop we got
to take care of each other we can't we
can't we got to put our heads together
and figure how to change the system so
that it works for people that's hardcore
range so whether it's Trump or whether
it's Hillary don't matter
that's not trauma that's not oh boy I
see all these people are gonna get
mobilized they're gonna be like
we've got to take control of our local
government in fact that is what you have
to do and that was what was so great
about kicking Monsanto off the Big
Island because Monsanto wasn't just
trying to legislate the type of seeds I
could use they were doing that yeah on
your own land that's what they're trying
to tell you what to do that's what they
do here yeah I'm just trying to watch
what grows on my own right because that
was like all the experiments for a
hundred years by dull pineapple and [ __ ]
some odd [ __ ] [ __ ] grows over there
right I like take pictures of it it's
crazy mm-hmm oh I know what I was going
to say not only were they try to tell us
what we could plant but what the real
thing is is they were trying to make
local government obsolete and that is
what they're really doing they all do
two things the one is the circus for
idiots I shouldn't even say idiots the
unaware yeah and then there's a real
[ __ ] and they're trying to make local
government illegal for Christ's sake
that's what the Patriot Act is really
about so how do you fight the fight
you've got to get involved at the local
the smallest level is what matters
because that's how they did it that's
how they brought fascism to our country
using the war on drugs which was really
a war for drugs and I say it's rich
people on prescription drugs locking up
poor people on street drugs that's a war
on drugs for drugs and they brought
Mexico in but and Bill Clinton did it
all and there they are yeah we want him
back he sent all their jobs away NAFTA
got rid of aid to dependent children
some [ __ ] instead of universal
health care yes I mean if she gets in
I imagine the equal amount of people on
the other side are going to get
mobilized and start running for office
too and this is the great thing if there
is anything great about democracy it's
that you've got to work it for it to
work however I did have lunch one time
with a royal I won't say who because you
know
don't want put them it was there a good
person okay and she he told me said this
was their feeling on the subject people
did a lot better under Kings because you
know the king would take care of his
laborers he had to I mean you know I
have some slaves to she didn't see that
right like it somehow they forgot that
house is for him mm-hmm
you know we let them have doctors that
go to college and what they [ __ ] do
they start talking about democracy and
that's what they get and isn't Victor
Hugo said democracy is two walls and a
lamb deciding what to have for lunch so
it's the wild wild East and West but
there is a political compromising
between the two and that's what I write
about I do believe in freedom so it
seems to me that a lot of the things
that you're talking about we're sort of
all over the place here but there is a
there's a theme here sort of around
socialism but at the same time you're
really talking about the individual
because you're basically saying get your
[ __ ] right think right get local instead
of socialism as the Socialists define
socialism I'm for some socialist
solutions to problems yeah but that
doesn't mean that I'm a Stalinist it
actually sounds libertarian to me a lot
of things you don't like them because we
do need government yeah by God we need
intelligent efficient government so I
you know I I want a synthesis called
people ISM where we just like solve
[ __ ] problem right and and nobody's
getting rich off keeping the problem
going so when you ran you ran first for
the Green Party for people that don't
know it so you ran the Green Party
ticket for the Green Party nomination
for the nomination and you eventually
lost to Jill Stein who has run how many
times eighty-seven times before
there's nothing well their last
candidate before Jill Stein was Cynthia
McKinney right so was that far heart was
Ralph Nader right right so Jill though
struck me as when I watch the
documentary she's very much like a
politician like a normal politician and
you came into the Green Party language
yeah she spoke just the red but it
doesn't get you anyway
in the system right it doesn't the
Democrats and Republicans if you just
speak their language but you're not one
of them that's not going to get you into
the system and you basically were like
[ __ ] this I'm going to speak the way I
speak I'm going to talk about these
things and to me they could have jumped
on you and said this would be at least a
way of cracking the system a little bit
but they didn't ultimately they didn't
go with you
and then you ran stay tight and white
and you know they want the matching
funds again money I don't know on the
local level I'll say when I ran I did
get the nomination of the Peace and
Freedom Party and I was very excited
because there were a real Socialist
Party but then when I asked people to do
work for free they don't know I got to
make money for them and I said you you
don't get paid for being a revolutionary
and in my campaign you do it because you
have to do it you don't do it firm job
cuz those people I sell you out I want a
true believers fire in the bellies I got
a few of them and made it to three
ballots because of them mm-hmm and the
work they did they could cry out or got
the signatures you got like the sixth
most amount of votes right yeah only
three states and I took three states to
put me in six place out of 50 candidates
so I thought oh these are these are some
good things that people who come after
can can you know probably Kanye West
will be doing it until it's Rosanne
Kanye I could see it do you think we
have a chance you think we have a chance
to get out of this freaking thing so I
get what you're saying there's goodness
coming people are waking up and then yet
you're also talking about a lot of bad
stuff but in just terms of the political
stuff you think there'll be a chance
like could somebody actually good do it
well I did it yeah but but can someone
break through can I break this well
that's the question
can somebody we can break through in our
own ways can you do me yeah you're gonna
do it I'm right here you're gonna run in
2020 there anybody else but me no there
isn't and that's what really [ __ ]
pissed me off because people are like oh
she's doing and everything and I wanted
to show hey what if you really run for
the values all of America
they believe in they gotta vote for you
no but I you know that's disturbing
because that's just nothing but dirty
mind control and when you sit in front
of people yourself included sorry and
you say no I I have the answers I put a
lot of thought into how we're going to
live through the collapse of capitalism
and show me one other candidate who's
saying anything like that and there
isn't any and then they go well is there
a chance somebody could say something
and I'm saying I'm saying it you know
but because I'm uh I think it's because
I'm a woman I do and hot and I'm just
too [ __ ] smart oh you know people
can't accept me I can't be responsible
if people don't want to hear it I had to
really separate out from that if you
don't want to hear it [ __ ] them no I
don't think that there's any hope that
we're gonna live through this [ __ ] no I
don't I think there's an infant is Mille
I think it's 99% that will be all be
dead within 40 years and the earth with
it hmm
I think there's a 1% chance that if we
were to start taking care of each other
and valuing real [ __ ] like each other's
lives and getting food to hungry kids
and stopping all this [ __ ] if on the
off hand chance we would ever do the
right thing just this once I have great
hope that it would save everything I I'm
just so proud that I I think that I
wrote the words that kicked Monsanto out
of Hawaii and I know that to myself that
I I did that from my grandkids and other
people's grandkids and so you just want
to do what's right for kids and I'm not
going to stop yeah I I mean I think if I
know anything about you it's that you
won't stop that seems so obvious to me
just knowing you're your history which
we barely touched on and then everything
with the show and then everything I know
about you now like you this is the stuff
like it's not like one of these people
that come
on shows or they talk one thing and
they're living something else I've never
seen you sort of done that I did that I
did that the worst part in my life or I
like totally man alright let's do this
whoo yes man I don't ever want to go in
there yeah was that like that you're the
peak of your fame was that was that that
was that time yeah now some isolated
well yes really give me like a minute of
that what's that like when you when you
at that point you were making god knows
how much money and million are we yeah I
mean right so a million a week
that'd be longer there can that'd be
that one name be Beyonce lunch money
medals right but it was pretty good for
back then it was never the highest it
was pretty bright you you not Cosby off
number one you ran that you basically
took full control of the show pretty
much although you were fighting with
executive still yeah and all that stuff
but what was that when you think back to
that period of your life when you had
that much power do you know we don't
have to talk about the national anthem
thing but the President of the United
States said that you're you were
despicable and now it's afternoon that
right okay so but but that that Arden oh
right right now is the dance that wasn't
here right here was so what was that
what was it like when you think when you
think about it like what was it like to
be that much of a sort of cultural force
it was really lonely was scary lonely
yeah
psychopath [ __ ] vampires everywhere
yeah scary lonely um real isolating
lonely but it got where you want to be
if your comic yeah I mean we're loners
but we always need somebody to you know
be real with and that's just how it goes
no I see it you know I lived through it
that's how I look at it a lot of other
artists they didn't live through it a
lot of comics nowadays great comics
they're not living through it they're
homeless and I'm no teeth they were
great comics or snow nobody gets paid
for comedy nobody gets paid there's no
retirement or
there is there like one moment that you
regret in this chaos of that that time
nothing right no cuz it's all like [ __ ]
I can sit all day and think if I want
and I do a lot of it and read all day
and [ __ ] lay in bed and not take
shower for three days and have a stack
of magazines and somebody to bring me
food land ah could you bring me yeah
just great right and you can fight with
people on Twitter that's pretty good
yeah I got into that Twitter thing yeah
I tried to and gather like-minded bulk
and I I think that I've introduced maybe
20 of them so that was worth it I think
you got a couple people I like
introducing smart people to other smart
people and then they do something mm-hmm
and you know never call me again but
like take me up for dinner once a year
so don't ask me if I can Shepherd your
way through you two young people with
good ideas [ __ ] make something happen
leave me this you know make me proud of
you
I like introducing young people that
take action I'm proud of them but you
know I want to just play lay in bed
watch my murder shows and go to Costco
and get the samples I know you like that
- I love it yes so austere you do love
it every time I'm having a sample at
Costco I think Roseanne looks oh God and
they're good that's pretty good yeah
real good
they're good now food [ __ ] that's great
yeah they should start selling the wine
- I think but they never do that they
never do that you can't get drunk and be
riding one of those giant carts oh those
people are all drunk yeah I think yeah
so I want to ask over hangout I want
because one thing that you were sort of
hitting on you were that that I've
talked about for a long time now is what
I call the regressive left these people
that are on the left that don't actually
stand for liberal values you call it the
fake left yeah and I saw you taught it
on Twitter probably two years ago before
I was really on this thing about their
aggressive you would always be talking
about the
fake left so when did you realize that
there ran for green part president when
I saw you know oh man these guys are all
rich they're just wanting matching funds
so they can go to Suarez and cocktail
parties you know instead oh I just met
like somebody who was a huge donor
Democrat things this was way back when
mm-hmm and their spouse was at a party
the spouse came in all in designer [ __ ]
and goes can I say something I'm having
labor issue I was like why do i why am I
always there to see that funner thing
I'm always there seeing like oh my
[ __ ] god why am I seeing this yeah so
of course I can't shut up like you kind
of [ __ ] you're you're gonna get your
[ __ ] ass sued and handed to you
there's labor laws look you can't break
[ __ ] labor laws can you not make your
maid wear a maid's outfit is that I
guess if they sign a Hollywood release
or some [ __ ] you tell them it's a
reality show around anything right but
uh it's all just [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're not Pro Union when's the last
time you heard [ __ ] Jill Stein say a
goddamn word about union labor well it
just doesn't happen
yeah it's about boycotting Israel and
that's what they're all about because
that anti-semite [ __ ] it works and those
guys are those Pharaohs right in the
checks that's a great misdirection wait
so it's not the Jews writing the checks
though did you know it's Pharaoh's so
you've become a huge defender of Israel
which i think is amazing because I in
this business always been what I thought
was a defender of Israel on one eye
um cuz when I was a little girl that was
my whole life
this is you know Palestine we called it
before they stole that word from us but
my uncle's used to sing if your name is
a B join the Jewish Navy five five five
for Palestine that wasn't you know that
you know that's how it was and Palestine
was where the Jews lived that's why the
Arab boycotted Palestine yeah yeah they
have had a boycott on Jews yeah Arabs
have four-way before Israel existed
hello it's just all [ __ ] and I think
that fake left what their cover is they
discover four empire an empire
you know royal Empire Pharaohs you know
they stole all the money of the Iraqi
Jews and kicked them out all the time
the fake left was not talking about
labor and and ethnic cleansing of Jewish
wealth in the Arab world because they
were getting paid by the Pharaohs to say
that [ __ ] I knew it was fake I knew it
was fake when I addressed the Green
Party delegates in Florida in 2011 and
I'm like you got to get rid of stand
your ground gun line they didn't know
about Trayvon Martin I think it hadn't
happened yet
that was a stand-your-ground I knew that
was [ __ ] not a good law for people
mm-hmm
you know and it's all based on how are
they going to lock up
pot smoking kids to go to those jails
and work for those corporations or 16
cents an hour
it's a predatory system I mean we know
enough to call it predatory lending but
it's way bigger and predatory lending
that's when you go to church to pray and
a pedo get you it's beyond predatory
it's a pirate predatory system and and
children are its prey and I don't like
them and I don't like anybody who aids
that and no grandmas do grandpas don't
either
but they're they're nodding off at the
television you don't have kids or
whatever decent people don't like that
kind of system and they don't even dare
look at it because they're like this
mm-hmm you know that's like when Moses
went and you know he killed the
taskmaster you know Moses was the Prince
of Egypt
anyone who killed that task matter
because it's like huh you can't be
you're gonna somebody bigger than you is
gonna come along and I guess that's just
the history of the world right who's
ever got the [ __ ] hammer wins yeah and
the [ __ ] hammer violence and all that
war stuff um that comes with whoever can
write the checks for the armies always
money for more bombs right we don't have
money for roads but there's always money
for more bombs except for now there's no
money so something new is here there's
no money sooner or later those chicks
are gonna bounce or some tragedy like
Dallas is gonna you know happen over and
over here you know people are gonna have
to do something different they're gonna
have to take care of each other that's
like why it's kind of good in a horrible
way
but I guess that's what that's the good
part that you don't worry supposed to
get to that anyway that's what tells us
we're supposed to do just you know take
care of each other and yeah can we end
this in a funny manner yeah let's get to
a funny place and this okay yeah I think
it's all funny yeah at the end of it but
this is all proof why you're a comic
right like at the end of the day all
this it's all like at the end at the end
I'll say this at the end like my
boyfriend Johnny says he's quoting
somebody and I can't remember who but
it's like everything strung together
with words everything's a narrative been
strung together with words and history
proves that yeah but uh words can take
it all apart too that's why comedies so
[ __ ] great cuz it's just like bam bam
I'm shooting right to the heart of the
beast which is in me okay I'm going to
uh
live for truth like I say I do I'm gonna
value truth and talk it and live it just
you know value it know cuz I know you
want me to not something funny
I think idiots are funny well we got
plenty of those I laugh at the idiot
system and that's the thing I was you
say about words laughing your idiot
system to scorn is the greatest gift
that comics freely offer a humanity and
you know like I said Doug Stanhope you
anybody who's funny or say anything real
[ __ ] go see em support them say go
further we want to hear more if I can
start laughing the [ __ ] to score
business just [ __ ] ridiculous it's
ridiculous that it doesn't work and that
it's like as stupid as it [ __ ] is all
right well listen I have a feeling oh
geez
I have a feeling we're gonna do this
again but I just want to take a second
just to thank you because you we met
only in the last three years or so but I
feel like you somehow saw something in
me that uh not really
no I just really I was just really drunk
no I thought I could take a bong hit and
it said hi to me so are you and your
smile yeah you know you laughed at my
joke so I go this guy's a genius and
then we started talking and you were
really funny made me laugh anyone who
can make me laugh I just value them
especially now we all need to laugh all
right well holy cow thank you to
Roseanne Barr we did a lot there if you
can follow around there's something
there you can find out more about
Roseanne at Roseanne world.com and I'm
pretty sure if you smoke enough weed you
will find her on the celestial plane so
thanks for watching I'll do it again
next week
you